what's up everyone we are back at the
blockchain economic forum we are
currently with oestrogen D hi thanks for
joining us on the show sweet so we met
what was it like two years ago when we
were doing science comedy show for yeah
for here a city that was super fun yeah
that was it was it was the best it was a
blast I remember when you when we
chatted I remember that like it was just
so important your role involved in
making sure that like you're kind of
like the glue like you're kind of like
the multiple hats of what's going on
inside of the massive organization that
is drape for you and hero City and
Draper ventures so now your partner at
Draper ventures congratulations yeah
okay just back and forth yeah so just to
explain so I think Draper university
more than me is the glue that binds all
of our ecosystem together and we started
with such an amazing idea of like really
teaching not only entrepreneurship but
changing the mindset of young people and
helping them understand how to solve
problems where were like 15 years out 20
years out and how to solve those
problems and eventually what she
realizes all right this is great people
are coming from all over the world
they're not only tapping into our
network but they're building great
companies but once they go there in this
space right there in this zone and
they're doing great things but once
they're done and they're going back to
their countries they're like hang on a
second what just happened right so
they're going through this entire face
of change so we kind of unfreeze them
change them but don't freeze them again
because we want them to continue
changing and learning but when they go
back to their countries there's nothing
or even once they step out of Silicon
Valley the support system is not there
so and being from Boggess on myself and
building likes working with startups
there or being hourly employee and
moving across like Middle East North
Africa I kind of understand where they
were coming from and we're like you know
what let's figure out we're figuring out
only one half of this equation so where
is the other half so now what Draper
University overall does is very
interesting because we've become the
educate
arm of art venture ecosystem which
nobody else kind of does or has so we
not educational arm in addition to their
ego exactly exactly and that works
wonders because so and that works
wonders because we now not only have
like entrepreneurial education we're
also doing corporate and investor
education and all of them together kind
of become this really nice melting pot
of not only ideas but capital clients
mentorship so it's very interesting and
now the fund itself invests in our
companies so I think we're very unique
in that aspect that we really get to
learn like live in the same building
with these entrepreneurs for five weeks
work with them on these ideas and really
help and we really see them grow so when
we're making a bet on them it still
might fail it's psycho enter capital we
get that but at the end of the day we're
now have a financial vehicle to support
them as well which is great hi you
explained it so well it's like this you
dis crucial minds and energies and
spirits coalescing from around the world
together and the the impact and
influence that somebody has like
somebody that's Pakistani or somebody
that's from South America or from
wherever they are in the world coming to
Silicon Valley not only do we get to
learn from their philosophies they get
to learn from what's going on here in
this massive technology boom get to this
network of mentors and entrepreneurs and
all these cool individuals that are
building the future here and then all of
a sudden they're know you're funding
them as well so now maybe tell us a
little bit about this because this is I
think this is important to break down
you said five so there's how many cycles
come in per year they come in for five
weeks the entrepreneurs do they come in
anywhere so we do different programs
depending on what stage the
entrepreneurs are at so they can be
anywhere from two weeks to five weeks we
bought a hotel so one of the biggest
costs of living in the Bay Area is
obviously housing so we kind of put
everybody in one space and then that
space also connects with our accelerator
so everybody who's going through boost
VC which is an accelerator
essentially there are thesis is we're
making Ironman a reality so anything
that's VR blockchain science fiction
they're investing in all of that so it's
so all these people live in this so all
these people sorry I walk a lot and move
a lot as I talk so a lot of these people
live in the same building so as you're
going up the elevator
you're like hey where are you working on
and what are you working on it starts
this conversation and builds like a
really collaborative learning
environment and all of a sudden we so
we're going back to that very Socratic
model of learning and I feel like when
these people come in from all across the
world they've really in a lot of
cultures we don't have a permission to
fail or we're like so focused on just
being perfect or an ego it's not even
something that's like gender specific
both men and women have such defined
roles that in order to like really solve
big problems or build companies that are
going to have that kind of impact we
don't even know where to start and then
all of a sudden you're here where
there's like all these amazing people
who kind of feel the same way as you do
but not only that they're also very
talented and can help you to do that and
when you add a capital arm to that then
that then enables you to do that I think
that's where an analysis in the next
like four or five years will really
start seeing the impact so it's taken us
a while to get the school to work oh
yeah but don't be like you said you
covered the housing cost that was so
crucial that was great and then now
maybe break down if you find a good a
good young adult that's building a
really impactful company you invest is
it fifty thousand two hundred thousand
four what percent etc sure
so we invest so just going back to our
investment thesis right so we're
investing in in serve like being
technology agnostic technology specific
or like saying hey we're only gonna
invest in this we're having very simple
thesis we're gonna invest in companies
that are disrupting areas where quality
of cost of doing service is really high
but the quality of service is really low
and that can be your government that can
be education health care supply chain
that can be anything and
and add frontier tech like blockchain
artificial intelligence BR AR or machine
learning all of these things together
and you really get a very interesting
mix of products or solutions that would
really leapfrog because in a lot of
markets outside of the United States for
example that mess on the computer like
you know era or who missed on the mobile
revolution these people there's no basic
infrastructure blockchain machine
learning all of these things will not
only bring the cost of it down but you
can actually build infrastructure much
faster now and with mobile adoption
things are already at scale right at
mass so I think the impact is already
there we just have to figure out we just
have to teach people how to not only
solve these problems but then also in
the last year and a half most of my work
unfortunately has not been with startups
it's actually been with local investors
local universities local capital in
markets helping them understand because
if we want to really take these risks
not all of that risk is Excel of that
capital has to come from these local
markets so helping them under helping
them understand that you're not
investing and you're not buying a
building or like somebody said to me if
this is that risky why don't I just buy
a cow and I was like you should buy a
couple and you'll be happy with your cow
giving you milk and like a two percent
return which is very safe but like
helping people understand that fine you
might lose 90 percent of the money that
you're going to put into these
entrepreneurs but that's okay they will
fail but then the returns when they do
succeed the problems that they solve the
impact of it their turns to fit
everything is going to be exponential so
yeah
oh god being a part of building the
future so important okay also come more
a little more Center again one more step
Center awesome perfect so now what about
what are you most looking forward to
regarding blockchain technology that's a
loaded question so again my basic thing
with a lot of people like Locke
is not hot sauce you can't put it on
everything and it's gonna taste good
right wait wait then I have to ask then
another question that we usually ask us
where is decentralization not applicable
like what would you not decentralize so
I don't think it's like a question of
where is the question of how so if
you're building a product do you need
like what a lot of times you don't need
all the coins all the crypto most of
this is like a Ponzi scheme but what
that does is it takes away the
conversation from real infrastructure
level work that needs to be done so
there's a lot of work an identity
there's a lot of work in smart contracts
all of those things are really building
that base layer so for example we
recently are more like Tim recently
invested in an and we bought an island
with the pup with the government of
Papua New Guinea to build economic like
a new economic zone and that's
interesting that's a lot of like basic
infrastructure level work and a lot of
markets your bonds are still on paper
your records are still on paper your
deeds are still on paper and all those
things blockchain can solve really fast
really well other things or like
healthcare records and all of that so
that level of detail is where blockchain
would really really help and also like
help scale things a lot we might not
necessarily need like crypto creases
great example right and like gets
everybody involved gets the conversation
started and that happens with Internet
as well right when people come and pitch
companies to us
half of them like sometimes it's like
hey this is a faster way of ordering
pizza and other times it's like we're
curing type-2 diabetes right so I think
we're still in that phase where we have
more people building on blockchain I was
like quick ways of making money versus
people really understanding and being
smart about the future and I think the
conversation is slight like moving like
last year was all about I cos a lot of
people got rich a lot of people lost a
whole bunch of money but now slowly
that's like how basic economics works
the markets will start
stabilizing themselves the market is so
new that we haven't even scratched the
surface of what's possible but at the
same time if I want to build something I
will look at the technology and not at
just like crypto is only a part of it
but the underlying technology is where
the real magic is and I think we haven't
scratch the surface of that I like all
the fields that you listed and I know
that that are they're gonna be very
important and applicable for a
decentralization technology and I also
really like how you made it clear that
that these basic infrastructure changes
towards decentralization are really
what's going to be the massive awesome
civilizational shift versus just the
kind of like the little like faster
pizzas and like decentralized pizza yeah
yeah all this kind of stuff again there
are people who like ordering pizza is a
problem for them and totally totally but
is it but is it as big of a problem as
somebody getting killed and not having
their identity just be lost because they
didn't have it on any decentralized
Ledger's there's Ledger's so there's
there's many more important issues No
so that's I think there's a lot of more
pressing issues that blockchain can
really resolve for us and as we grow as
humanity we will see more and more so
one of the things that I absolutely
believe in is that we need to move away
from this like I want to live in the US
but it cuz it has like better standard
of living or when I live in Canada
because it has better healthcare to like
these are better citizens and I want
them so governments competing for
citizens women capital for human capital
versus human capital trying to figure
out how where do I go right so for
example in most emerging markets the
education system is completely broken
but that is the only way to get out of
that market like if you want to get out
of let's say Pakistan or Africa or
anywhere you have to go to school you
have to get a degree that you've spent
that teaches you nothing pretty much
then you apply for college you get
student loans and get through all of
that and I think all these fundamental
processes is what will eventually change
with the onset of technology and where
we're at
yes I really loved the idea of kids from
around the world being able to access a
really the most efficient educational
content free of cost
I love that idea and see Cato foundation
is doing a really great job of that
they're actually one of our educational
partners go see k12 plug seriously you
guys do you guys know Nero Nero Khosla
and see k12 I really want to I'll
connect you guys to the to the Draper
ventures team okay couple speed round
questions a lot of what we talk about on
the show has to do with like wealth
inequality and globalization just
because we think that these are very
pressing issues that are going on like
how do we work together across the world
without sacrificing like geopolitical
leadership to make sure things are safe
for everybody and also like what are we
gonna do about wealth inequality where
the top richest people in the world are
getting wealthy and wealthy or meanwhile
the bottom is just very slowly
increasing in wealth so I don't know if
it's a traditional answer or not but I
kind of look at it from a slightly
different perspective I think so and
because I'm from an emerging market like
I grew up in Pakistan I'm only moved out
of Fox than six years ago and one of the
things that I always tell other people
is that we don't have when we're talking
about change or like we have to be very
selfish about it right because you
cannot impact or work on something that
you fundamentally don't believe in and a
lot of that is very uncomfortable and
you have to be very very alone in that
journey for the most part we can build a
lot of like human capital or we can help
people get there but the conversation
has to be around how important it is to
respect who you are as a human what
rights you have as an individual and
then respecting your time and your mind
with and I'll give you an example of
that so for example I don't watch TV I
haven't watched any TV or listen to
music or anything for about 15 16 years
now
but when I made that small change in my
life
I had to find new friends Yeah right and
that's like when I was in my - like
early early 20s and it was hard right a
lot of times it's like not everybody is
going to save the world but people who
are going to save the world are going to
be very lonely in that process so how do
we build more like how do we build
support systems around that how do we
give them easy access to capital or how
do we enable and empower them to do
better I think that's where at least I
focus most of my work on because that's
what I want to achieve and then I think
once we start doing that more and more
people learn from that example of being
not being not afraid of talking about
big ideas and it's fine if it fails like
if it doesn't work out so for example I
remember for the very long ever since I
was a kid I've been fascinated by tall
buildings and at some point I was like
you know what I want to live in vertical
cities that's what I want I want to
build where I don't want to build a new
island I would love to go to Mars but I
want to figure out how do we build
vertical cities in the long run would
have learnt is these are all these are
problems of syrup sorry so these are all
problems of economics right so a lot of
it is okay if we're building a vertical
city do we build a new economic solution
around that to build a new education
solution around that and with the fund
every time I'm investing in a company or
if I'm looking at it in the back of my
mind I'm always thinking about hey if I
build a vertical city or if I find all
these amazing people and we decide you
know what we want to build these do we
have the construction mechanisms for it
do we have materials for it do we have
economic like systems in place for it
anything a lot of these like blockchain
machine learning all of these things
come together like robotics for that so
it's always like it's important to have
that overarching on it maybe even an
achievable goal as a human being
yourself and then finding people kind of
working on the problem backwards finding
people who agree with you fundamentally
on that level and then figuring out what
role can you play in empowering people
that you've met
along the way so you get to that
overarching goal of yours and we be very
unapologetic about it but I think with
that you're in at least it's a theory
that I test for myself all the time I
feel like my impact is greater versus if
I just want to help people for the sake
of helping people Baddeley's has never
worked out for me there's a seems to be
a couple things that you said that that
are crucial in the globalization and
wealth and quality conversation one of
them I think was this kind of notion of
like self actualization being at the
forefront of kind of everything that you
do like you get to pick what you do with
your time and that's the most important
thing that we do and so if we're gonna
pick things that are going to help us
advance these goals that are bringing
utility to the world we're gonna slowly
surround ourselves with more of those
people and be able to help make a better
world in that sense and hopefully
they'll do things like really solve
those big big problems okay couple other
speed round questions is do you think
we're alone in the cosmos no unpack that
a bit more so I definitely think
Humanity is or at least I always sound
like the best thing that ever happened
to me and the same way I feel like we
are the best thing that ever like we're
one of the most amazing things to have
happen on the universe like so many
things had to have you know worked well
and were like incidents had to happen
for us to exist that would be such a
waste to not utilize this life to live
to your fullest potential that that's
one but at the same time there is so
much more to the universe it's like a
very and it can go like dark very easily
right there are days when I'm just like
maybe we're just living in a simulation
and I'm like and then I spent like a
month going down that rabbit hole and
I'm like no life is too good to be in
that to be a simulation so I can't I
kind of go back and forth and like not a
very stable believer when it comes to
like that but I definitely think we're
not we can't be alone the universe like
there's so many there is so much more
out there and then it doesn't have to be
another human race it could be anything
do you think there's a designer to the
universe here's how I think of this I'm
a very like somebody who's very driven
by my own ambition or like my own like I
want to define things around me and I
think we can design the universe design
the world that we want to live in
however the minute you say like you know
what there is somebody else who designed
it you're accepting a fade that's
somebody else set for you and that's my
fundamental problem with saying yes or
no to that question so as I still want
to be in control of designing the world
that you live in or the word universe
that we're a part of right but it could
potentially be both happening at the
same time all the time
ya know the only person who's like
working on designing this like universe
of the world right so yeah and then what
about what do you think the most
beautiful thing in the world the human
mind
definitely hands down why oh the
potential of it just the fact that we
can like imagine we went from the cave
to here pretty very fast to the fact
that we're now and yes it's used for
both good and evil whatever but the fact
that we can differentiate between good
and evil that in itself and when you
look at what you're surrounded by right
other organisms other species and you
just look at every single thing around
you it's because of the human mind
nothing else it's because if somebody
who said you know what I don't accept
this as the only answer and I'm going to
explore more and learn why and that's it
that's how we got here and that's how
we'll get wherever we get yeah I'm not
I'm not satisfied with with the current
state of things I am but I'm also really
wanting to make the world a better place
and so the human mind continuing to
propel itself forward to do things like
eradicate suffering and make more of
these great experiences for ourselves
I'm just really excited to see
happens after the census how we can
start plugging into more experiences to
make us feel really alive excited about
that again I think I've always felt very
alive and it's also something very like
if you understand that this is your only
life and the only person like Elias like
you know your life needs to have a
purpose that's beyond what you think oh
I can just achieve this tomorrow and be
happy with so for me for example I'm
like you know what I want to be immortal
but what does a mortality mean I don't
want to live forever but I want to
create something that lives forever or
and I just want some people are just
like you know what I want to help people
really understand how like the innermost
like you know that innermost spot of
comfort that you have in your mind how
do I tap into that how do I tap into my
maximum human potential so whatever it
is that your goal is would make you feel
alive every single day and if you're
waking up and not happy about something
that you're doing don't do it this is
the only life you have why would you
even spend again respect your mind
respect your time why would you do
something that makes you unhappy you
have a choice
exactly also thank you so much for
coming on to the show we greatly
appreciate it this has been a blast you
should come down to Draper and do more
like fun stuff there too I know we have
a lot of really brilliant young people
to interview there and and you know I
haven't mentored in like eight months or
twelve months or something so I need a
comeback I would love to I will there's
that the ecosystem that you guys have
created there is really beautiful and
I'm glad that you got to mention that at
the beginning and we'll put the links in
the bio for everybody to check out also
make sure to go and tell two people
about what you learned today have them
tell two people comment below with your
thoughts subscribe share the video with
other people go consume would go create
with this content don't just consume
join us on patreon to help us support
the studio and the process and getting
us up to sports stadium so so we can
continue coming to cool place
like washing economic form and
interviewing epic people thank you and
if you ever feel alone or if you ever
feel like I really want to do this but I
don't know how feel free to hit us up
we'll be happy to and even if we can't
fund it just talk to you about it
because sometimes all you need is people
who understand what you're saying and I
think that's one thing that we've been
able to build in our ecosystem really
well so if you're ever on the word of
changing the world but feeling very
alone we're here for you that's huge for
entrepreneurs to be able to reach out to
somebody and have them care about what
they're aiming to build so definitely
reach out thanks everyone for tuning in
much love bye thanks for coming on the
show